in-cell god jordan peterson was the
basis for don't worry darling bad guy so
this is an article from the independent
talking about an interview with olivia
wilde who is the director for this new
film and in a recent interview with
interview magazine wilde spoke to fellow
actor maggie gyllenhaal about the
inspiration behind frank's character we
based that character on this insane man
jordan peterson who is this
pseudo-intellectual hero of the incel
community wild said she further
explained that the incels as a community
of disenfranchised mostly white men who
believe that they are entitled to sex
from women they believe that society has
now robbed them and that the idea of
feminism is working against nature and
we must be put back into the correct
place wild added peterson began reading
blah blah blah wild continued this guy
jordan peterson is someone that
legitimizes certain aspects of the
incels movement because he's a former
professor he's an author he wears a suit
so they feel like this is a real
philosophy that should be taken
seriously what do you think
about this william
uh i think
a lot of thoughts the first one is if
you're gonna cast anybody in a jordan
peterson type character you need to pick
daniel day lewis i think he would just
nail a jordan peterson biopic
when that comes about
but yeah it's obviously just so wide of
the mark on so many fronts and
i'm reminded immediately about a
specific video that i watched jordan
peterson record and it's the only one
where as far as i'm aware he talks
directly to incels so he's asked about
this kind of wider mating crisis of why
more and more men
seem to be struggling to to find
relationships and he basically gives
classic quintessential finger wagging
jbp jordan peterson advice patriarch
pull your boots up stuff yeah get your
act together if every woman in the world
doesn't want you they're not wrong and
you know he comes down with some serious
tough love
for any man that kind of think things
like that i would say to young men who
are irritated at women
is if you're irritated at women you know
as a class of creature there's something
wrong with you because they're right
you're wrong
they're right
to not pick you if they're not picking
you it's because they're right he does a
great job of separating the the kind of
cultural or a group or higher level
factors that might be making it more
difficult uh foreign individual men to
find relationships but he as always
focuses on the sovereignty of the
individual and he says that cultural
thing is not your problem your problem
is you and
just one second here why are you
an authority to speak about incels why
should anyone that's watching this video
believe what you've got to say with any
authority
right okay so i should explain i did my
master's um thesis on the psychology of
incels i've just recently graduated from
brunel university in london with a
master's in psychology culture and
evolution i'm currently a phd student
here at uh ut austin uh studying under
with the the supervision of dr david
boss
and uh yeah i'm i'm focusing a lot more
research on the incel topic and
my study for my master's dissertation is
one of the highest um participant counts
for an incel study out there so
we have some findings that directly
refute um olivia wilde's claim certainly
that it's a
predominantly white movement there's a
significant portion of the encelosphere
that are in cells of color
and in fact 36
and a half percent of my sample of 151
in cells
were in cells of color and that's in a
majority u.s and uk samples
disproportionately yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that's immediately poorly
researched on the behalf of olivia wilde
but but also just to classify jordan
peterson a 30-year career as a professor
one of the most cited personality
psychologists out there stellar academic
career to classify him as just
pseudo-intellectual or pseudoscience
it's just it's really
wide of the mark
did you ever speak to incels about
jordan peterson did he ever come up
because you did a ton of qualitative
interviews as well as this huge survey
that gave you a ton of data that you
analyzed did he ever come up
uh he comes up sometimes in the
individual conversations for any incels
who
who think that they still have hope of
engaging with the mating market and want
to kind of develop themselves but it's
always in a classically
positive light i've always he's making
me believe i can make tomorrow better
than yesterday and just
only in that self-development type of
thing they never really used jordan
peterson rhetoric as an excuse for being
in sales because it wouldn't work i
don't understand how you could align
jordan peterson's approach for men that
there isn't a single time and i've
watched a lot of his stuff there isn't a
single time that i can remember where
he's placed the blame of the
ineffectiveness of men in the dating
market at their own feet he has always
said well you better pull those
bootstraps up bucko like that's that's
his bag right he is saying
if all of the women don't like you
it's not the women it's you you are the
common denominator between all of these
situations what do you expect from women
if you got pregnant because you had sex
you'd be pretty damn choosy too
so you know clue in a bit and then well
don't they find you attractive well
maybe you're not
like have you paid attention to how you
dress do you have a plan
are you as educated as you could be
you know
are you liar
are you a rabid pornography user because
maybe that's undermining your motivation
to
seek out a woman and
grow yourself up speaking of common
denominators i wasn't familiar with
olivia wilde before this story came out
i recognized her from some movies uh
sheila labeouf was supposed to star in
the film but she got replaced by
olivia's boyfriend harry styles because
shya's process wasn't conducive to the
film continuing forward then a video got
leaked that she had sent to shire saying
that she still was broken up about all
of this and that she very much wanted to
have him back florence pugh another star
of the show isn't doing any press
on this uh press tour because she fell
out with olivia as well
my point being it doesn't strike me as
olivia
common thread between everything olivia
wilde happens to be one of them when it
comes to uh news stories
yeah well there's a joke there if
somebody calls you a horse the first
time you punch them in the face if they
call you a horse the second time you get
really mad at them if they call you a
horse for a third time it's time to buy
a saddle so that idea of a common
denominator you know and perhaps maybe a
top spin on a news cycle might be just
what olivia wilde needed and maybe
wanted to start this i i couldn't
possibly speculate yeah having a look at
obviously the movie's not out yet the
movie is called don't worry darling and
based on what i've seen on the
on the trailer it's got this sort of um
handmaid's tale ish kind of tilt to it
it looks like all of the women stay at
home and all of the men go out to work
it's got this sort of 1960s aesthetic as
well uh and one thing that's really
interesting is gas lighting is literally
written into the title don't worry
darling right it's a little bit
condescending it's presumably the men i
don't know what it is but the men are
away doing something they say that
they're working but it seems like
there's suspicion around whether or not
they are and one of the characters goes
and does investigation and she's being
told that you're crazy and everything's
going to be fine like gaslighting is
literally written into the title so the
fact that
they used i mean i i don't understand
it simply strikes me as someone that's
never watched any of his content to be
able to say this jordan's got his flaws
man jordan isn't right about everything
but on this
it i i don't think that you could have
anything that's further from the mark
yeah even if you disagree with his
message his message on this is you know
against the incels or like against the
in-cell excuse me yeah how what is the
in-cell excuse and how does jordan's
message diverge from what they typically
believe
so incels typically believe in what's
called black pill thinking which is a
derivative of the red pill from the
matrix to kind of see reality as it
really is
taking the black pill as
in their world view it kind of describes
that it was hopeless from the beginning
and that there's nothing that incels
could do
to change their romantic prospect so it
was
there's no point in even trying whereas
that's antithesis of jordan peterson's
message his idea is you can always tilt
the world one way or the other towards
heaven or towards hell the way he kind
of
speaks about it and you know there's so
many men out there and i'm speaking
personally i started listening to jordan
peterson in about 2016 2017 and as an n
of one my life just skyrocketed
trajectory went straight up by just
following those principles and like you
you say chris there's plenty i probably
disagree with him on and uh maybe he's a
bit more bombastic than than i might
like at times um but yeah to say that
he's like an in-cell king and kind of
fortifies their world view
is just so wide with america actually
the more incels that would take his
message seriously they'd probably
benefit from it you know in-cell god not
in cell king in cell gods jordan
peterson was the basis for don't worry
darling bad guy if you were better
you'd be more successful with women
so you have to you have to have that in
your mind and they're not you cannot be
angry at women
it's stupid it seems like insults see
themselves and the world as immutable
and jordan's message is that both
yourself and vicariously the world
through you and the influences that you
have around it are mutable like you can
change the things that you do not like
about yourself and through that you can
affect the world in a much better place
yeah in ireland we have a phrase that
says you can't control the wind but you
can't control your sails and that's all
you can do really you you can kind of
try and cultivate this internal locus of
control
around your life but with the way jordan
peterson categorized it in that video i
thought it was very interesting um
because he basically suggests that if
all of the women in the world think this
about you or even if the majority think
this about you they're right and he kind
of that appeals to me because it kind of
it highlights the importance of female
sexual selection in in terms of driving
evolution and the in evolution we talk
about it like the mind of one sex shapes
the body and mind of the other so it's
this cyclical relationship of uh
whatever female sexual selection uh will
reward and male sexual selection to some
degree as well perhaps not as much um
will shape literally the body and mind
of the other i think that's kind of a
beautiful way to look at it and uh
motivating men around this idea of
female sexual or romantic reward has
been you know the catalyst in a lot of
male development of themselves and then
wider society there's a episode of
futurama where everybody gets sex robots
and the entire world just grinds to a
halt and the they pan out and they go
wow it really was all about sex after
all
yeah yeah i mean
my supervisor david boss he did some of
the earliest mate preference studies uh
in the late 1980s early 90s and then he
decided to take a break from studying uh
romance and mating and he said i'm going
to study something totally different i'm
going to study murder and what did he
find out it's actually often all about
sex or romance as well the the
motivations are very often attributable
to amazing goals so yeah it's the only
game in town
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you